hi I'm Erik Bosse and since Star Wars
the last Jedi released a teaser a couple
months back we've been getting a ton of
new interesting details about this movie
not just the new characters and story
details but kind of crazy theories and
what kind of tone this movie will have
who's kissing who who's sleeping with
who there's all kinds of crazy hot guys
so I'm going to update you on to
everything we know about the last Jedi
so far and even though there's so much
we still don't know about this movie if
you don't want to know anything about
this movie and just want to go in
completely blind there could be some
potential spoilers ahead so you've been
warned okay so let's start with the
characters writer director Rian Johnson
said that he started with a list of all
the characters in the movie and then he
came up with the most difficult
struggles that each of those characters
would have to go through so let's look
at all the returning characters from the
force awakens
Luke Skywalker and Rey seem like they're
going to be the main focus of this film
at least according to the teaser in the
way that the force awakens left off so
we know that Luke will be mentoring and
kind of training raid but Rian Johnson
says it won't be exactly like the Jedi
training that we've seen in past films
like with Yoda and Luke and Empire
Strikes Back Daisy Ridley has said that
Rey meeting Luke will be similar to
people who meet their heroes where it's
impossible for them to live up to their
expectations so she's probably expecting
Luke to be the hero from legend the Jedi
pilot who blew up the Death Star and
defeated Darth Vader and kissed the
princess who ended up being his sister
but then when his fangirl comes up to
him Luke is just like oh sorry kid and
any no more get off my ocean Rock
meanwhile Mark Hamill has described his
character as a failure and we know that
his force training of his nephew Ben
solo who became kylo Ren yeah ended in a
disaster in fact that disaster might be
what we're seeing in that shot in the
teaser with Luke and r2d2 in front of a
burning Jedi Temple that could be a
flashback this whole tragedy is probably
part of the reason he said
time to the Jedi and and I'm predicting
that when we see Rey holding out the
lightsaber to Luke he might actually
refuse it it sounds like will also get
an answer to that question set up in the
opening crawl of the force awakens where
has Luke been Kathleen Kennedy the
president of Lucasfilm said that in the
way that Episode seven was in a lot of
ways Han Solo's story episode 8 will be
Luke's story so we're going to find out
what exactly he's doing on this island
on the planet h2 where apparently we now
know an ancient Jedi Temple is located
meanwhile Rey will deepen her Jedi
training behind-the-scenes footage shows
Daisy brigly was some mad lightsaber
skills and apparently the last Jedi will
shed more light on the mystery of raised
parentage Brian Johnson said that the
movie will address that mystery but he
cut himself off before you any further
it will be addressing there will be the
clarification it depends on I'm not I
can't say it I was about to say Oh got
me I'm thinking he's about to say
depends on what you mean by
clarification so I'm predicting that
we'll learn more about raised origin but
that answer will set up an even deeper
mystery okay moving on we also know that
general Leia Organa will be a big part
of this movie now just be clear Carrie
Fisher did finished shooting all of her
scenes for this movie however according
to Kennedy Leia was going to be an even
bigger part of episode 9 like it was
going to go hannes movie for episode 7
luke's movie for episode 8 and then
Leia's movie for episode 9 but since she
passed away that movie is undergoing
extensive rewrites
but for this movie in the teaser we saw
Leia looking at a holo display onboard a
resistance ship which I pointed out in
my teaser breakdown could be the Mon
Calamari flagship cold one I say that
because that's Admiral Ackbar in the
background there also in the shot you
can see Ken lungs character from the
force awakens
Admiral UO datura now another returning
character will be Poe Dameron a quick
shot in the teaser showed him with bb-8
on a resistance basis that was under
attack we also know that at some point
he gets in an argument with Leia and she
slaps them according to Oscar Isaac they
did this take 27 times and every time
she'd hit like a different spot in my
face and that brings us to the guy that
post sheriff jackets with and Gordon
John boyega spin is still recovering
from the nasty lightsaber
that Kyllo gave them in the force
awakens and now boyega says that Finn is
in a back to suit fact that's probably
what we saw him in in the teaser in our
breakdown I pointed out that the are
vege letters here translate to stable
now I'm not totally sure if a back to
suit in boyega's words is different from
a back to tank like what we've seen Luke
and Vader use maybe suit means it's more
portable I also pointed out in the
teaser that the flashing blue light on
the edges of the frame look like this
tank slash suit could be traveling
through hyperspace anyway apparently
thin will be going on a side adventure
with a new character who we'll get to in
a second but next there's kylo Ren we
don't know much about how kylo will
respond to his defeat in the force
awakens we know that he now has a sick
face scar and he was able to retrieve
his lightsaber despite seemingly losing
in the force awakens we also saw this
mysterious shot of its crushed helmet
smoking now we also now know from the
Vanity Fair photo shoot that general Hux
and Captain phasma will also be
returning phasma actually appeared
briefly in the teaser as well and I'm
predicting she'll be the one leading the
first orders assault on the resistance
base and I'm sure chewy r2 and 3po will
show up as well but for now let's move
on to the new characters so kelly marie
tran will be joining the cast as rhodes
si is a maintenance worker for the
resistance and she'll be the character
who's joining thin as they head to canto
bites at the new casino planet so my
prediction is that rose is the
resistance worker who's responsible for
carting around Finn's back to suit as
he's in a coma and when the first-order
fleet shows up she has to escape within
and get into safety which will lead to
all kind of fun high jinks between these
two we also know that Vietnamese actress
veronica know will be playing roses
sister Paige who's a resistance pilot in
training then laura dern is also going
to be in the last Jedi she's playing
resistance officer Vice Admiral hold o
she wears this elaborate posh costume
with a violet wig and her character
appears on Kanto bite she's part of this
wealthy elite class and before I talk
about this new society one last new cast
member is a mysterious villain played by
Benicio del Toro now this guy apparently
didn't even get a name in the script
ryan johnson refers to him as DJ for a
reason that he won't tell anyone
and some are speculate
that he's the guy who runs Cantor by the
way that Lando Calrissian brand Cloud
City or maybe DJ refers to him being the
disc jockey of the galaxy controlling
the rhythm in the timing deciding when
exactly to drop the beat guys I think
we're looking at snow just one second
I'm going to put on my tinfoil hat okay
let's move on to the planets and
locations in the last Jedi the exciting
new planet that people have been talking
about is Kanto bite it's the casino
planet Rian Johnson actually described
it as a playground for rich [ __ ]
it's meant to kind of be a refuge
vacation spot for the upper-class and
the galaxy to kick back and unwind while
the war goes on around them Pablo
Hidalgo from Lucasfilm described the
society as a class of wealthy that has
helped to build all sorts of loopholes
of society that will always ensure that
they'll survive or thrive no matter what
else is happening out there and this is
interesting because Kanna byte looks
like the first Star Wars location that
we've seen after the Galactic Civil War
is broken out that is completely removed
from political or military conflicts
like even Maz Eisley cantina and Cloud
City were eventually dragged into the
war so be curious to see how bin
responds to all these rich snobs who can
afford to live inside a bubble and not
really care at all about the galactic
war now another new location is the
planet crate we saw a quick shot of
crate in the teaser Rian Johnson
described it as a remote uncharted
planet with lots of minds on it and that
might be why the dust underneath the
desert surface is bright red it could be
the minerals in the soil that have been
oxidized anyway I love the vibrant color
palette for this planet it's nothing
like anything we've seen before in a
Star Wars movie and of course we know
that a major battle will take place on
this location we also know that the
resistance base on Dakar will show up at
least in the first act of the film in
fact it looks like there'll be a space
battle above this planet's surface with
resistance frigates forming a blockade
formation against a fleet of TIE
fighters in considering this is the only
space battle that we've seen any shots
of this might be what we pan to after
the opening crawl of the movie in as I
mentioned before another place that
we'll see more of is Luke's planet of
Aceh to Ryan Johnson described as silent
as a kind of Jedi village and that Luke
has been living in this village among an
indigenous race of caretaker creatures
and he was super secretive but he joked
that they weren't
but I'm curious to know what this race
is and why Johnson is being so
mysterious about it like it could be
that this race will be Yoda's species
something that's always been a big
mystery in the Star Wars universe and
again I've always kind of preferred Yoda
being this unknown mystery figure okay
let's talk quickly about the new ships
and weapons that we know about in the
last Jedi so of course there's the
inclusion of the a wing Starfighter we
saw quick glimpses of the a wing and the
resistance hangar and in that big space
battle remember we saw aliens and return
the Jedi and there's also these new
resistance fighters that we saw in the
shots on crate they kind of look like
bee wings but they aren't they're a new
kind of land speeder that flies close to
the ground with these low lying anchor
pieces that drops down to kick up that's
red dust my breakdown is speculated that
they're doing that deform it's kind of
visibility shield to make the part of
the target and these things that they're
flying toward is a new type of first
order Walker called gorilla walkers and
they're called that because they're a
lot larger and they have bigger sturdier
front arms okay finally I want to touch
on some of the deeper theories that have
come up about the last Jedi first big
one what does the last Jedi refer to and
one of the most interesting developments
is that the Jedi in the title might
refer to more than one Jedi in fact the
Spanish translation of the title
revealed that it is indeed plural but no
one from the movie or Lucasfilm have
confirmed this yet so it's possible that
the last Jedi isn't just Luke it could
be Luke rey and horde dozens of other
characters like the last colony of Jedi
now why does Luke say that it's time for
the Jedi to end
now once area that I brought it before
is that Luke could be a gray Jedi now a
gray Jedi is an obscure concept from the
Star Wars universe that refers to Jedi
who are on the border between the light
and the dark side of the force it also
refers to Jedi who operate outside of
the Jedi Order and the idea here is that
Luke after learning how his father could
come back from the dark side and how the
old Jedi Dogma kind of failed him when
he tried to teach them to bend all this
might end up with Luke having mixed
feelings about the force
seeking a new open-minded less binary
worldview that would require the old
tradition of the Jedi as he sees it to
end now another theory centers around
those old books that show up in the
teaser these pages contain
a symbol of the Jedi Order and some
people are saying that these books could
be the ancient journal of the Wills
now the Wills are from George Lucas's
original script for a new hope he
imagined the story of Star Wars to be an
old legend recorded by an advanced alien
race called the will and this story that
takes place a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away are recorded in their
journal now this was an idea that Lucas
removed from its screenplay draft but
ever since she written bathes in rogue
one were considered guardians of the
Wills the theory is that now the whole
concept of wills are being brought back
into Star Wars as part of the origin of
the force so maybe by seeking or
decoding this journal of the Wills Luke
will begin to finally understand a true
nature of the force and how the Jedi
tradition misinterpreted that truth so
now that Luke will understand it's time
to move beyond the Jedi and another
related theory involves the idea of
force trees now I've gone into the
backstory of force-sensitive trees in my
teaser breakdown but when you look even
more closely at the teaser this cave
that Luke is inside kind of looks like
it's the inside of a tree trunk like
notice the wall behind the bookshelf has
this wooden root texture which is
similar to the surfaces around Luke as
these stands in the portal at the end of
the teaser this could be all part of the
same interior location that Luke lives
inside which might be the ancient Jedi
Temple which was built inside of a tree
like the Keebler elves but instead of
baking delicious cookies Luke is used to
ministry to meditate and deepen his
understanding of the force now again
that's just a delicious theory but one
last theory that I've been playing
around with which I kind of liked
something that I noticed when I
rewatched the first part of the teaser
it's interesting that raised right hand
suddenly drops in the frame and it's
kind of a jump-scare
now this movie is truly about rage
trying to follow in Luke's footsteps a
maybe the second chapter of this trilogy
will end with race up reen a similar
face that looted an empire boozing her
right hand and yeah I know that's kind
of crazy and also kind of like too neat
and predictable and convenient but if it
ends up happening it'll be crazy -
Kovach and see this all being
foreshadowed in our first-ever look at
the last Jedi now I go deeper into some
of these theories and a lot of other
interesting miscible details and my
breakdown to the last Jedi teasers so
make sure to go watch that but the most
important thing to know is that the last
Jedi is probably going to be really good
everyone who's read Rian Johnson's
script it's that good things to say
about it they love the weird new choices
Johnson has made and how dark the movie
gets but also how really fun and true to
Star Wars it is and force awakens
director JJ Abrams said that after
reading the script he said that he
wished he had written it himself and I
think that's a good sign so do you think
the last Jedi will deepen the mythology
of the force and the Jedi and Luke in a
way that feels satisfying or do you have
any concerns that they're tinkering with
our precious pseudo religion also now
that we know that Leia's story is being
rewritten for episode 9 what do you
think that the original plan for a
character was going to be let me know
what you think in the comments and if
you're into this kind of thorough know
it all the explanations of Star Wars
stuff please like this video and share
it around and we'll make more videos
answering any other question that you
might have about Star Wars and be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars to stay
up-to-date on all the in-depth Star Wars
coverage that we do on this channel you
can also be more part of our team here
by contributing to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current donors
especially Pony Starks tweet me any
theories or questions that you have
about the last Jedi at EA box you can
also follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for updates on our videos
and some exciting things coming up on
this channel alright thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
[Music]